[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I was recently at the
Google Zeitgeist conference,
and I was riveted by a talk on
the power of female education.
And the speaker says--
interesting line--
if you change the prospects
of an adolescent girl
on a big enough scale, you
will transform societies.
In this hyper-connected
world, we cannot lose sight
of the feminine force that
graces our planet and lives
beyond the Earth in
the stratosphere.
Throughout history, women
have broken boundaries
and transformed societies--
Rosa Parks, Marie Curie,
Indira Gandhi, Mother Teresa.
Where would we be
if these women had
been denied their basic
right to education?
When you educate a girl,
you educate a nation.
Malala captivated
our hearts and minds
when she bravely stood up
for her right to education.
But little girls should not have
to risk their life for this.
The cost of excluding
girls is high.
In Uganda, for
example, 85% of girls
leave school early,
resulting in $10 billion
in lost potential earnings.
But by delaying child marriage
and early birth for girls,
countries like Bangladesh could
potentially add $60 billion
to the national income over
these girls' lifetimes.
Investing in young girls
can accelerate the fight
against poverty, inequality,
and gender discrimination.
There's overwhelming evidence,
overwhelming evidence
that girls' education is
the most consistent driver
of development goals.
Business as usual is not enough.
And so on this day, as we
celebrate International Girls
Day, let us put
out that message,
empower women, educate
women, connect women.
Leverage emerging technologies,
bring them together
to create a network where
the sacred feminine can bring
that voice to cause a ripple
in the global conversation.
The next time you see
a little girl, just
think, she could
be the next person
to change the course of history.
[MUSIC PLAYING]